we got to start from the post-millennial
surprise surprise these people are lying
again Washington Post retracts false
claim that Ralph yarrow was killed in
Missouri shooting it's not the first
time they've done this where they've
claimed that some some story was someone
was killed when it was like no they're
actually not dead and this is another
one why well the story goes out as the
saying goes the LIE travels halfway
around the world before the truth can
strap on his boots
this story comes out from the Washington
Post where they say that this kid was
killed you get protests you get angry
you get animosity they then come back
and say whoops he's alive actually but
this is the story they've been pushing
in the media which to me makes uh almost
no sense why is this story
a national story is it sad sure you know
I I'm I'm sad when anybody gets shot for
something like this but I'll tell you
what I'll break it down for you simply I
think they're lying I'll tell you why
the story is Ralph yarl the black 16
year old boy who was shot twice after
accidentally ringing the doorbell of the
wrong home when picking up his brothers
is crying buckets of tears his mother
told CBS News full stop
he didn't accidentally ring the doorbell
he intentionally rang the doorbell at
the wrong house
so you see how that they're already
trying to frame it here he accidentally
rang the doorbell at this wrong house no
no he intentionally did it he
intentionally parked in the driveway got
up the house went there and it was just
the wrong house you can say he
accidentally went to this house
but he intentionally rang the doorbell
and went up to the stairs and now here's
here I don't I think they've changed the
story several times
the uh let me see if I have the Tweet
here take a look at the original tweet
twitter preserved the metadata the
headline Kansas City team shot after
entering wrong house
and that makes you wonder
why did they change the headline why did
they initially report that this kid
entered the home
could it be that uh they got it wrong
the story is that the man this guy
Lester shot through the glass screen
door hitting the kid in the head and I
think in the shoulder or the upper chest
and that proves they say that he
needlessly just shot the kid however
they mention uh let me see if uh
here we only read this they say Andrew
Lester the 84 year old white white
homeowner who shot Ralph knows they
always include the races turned himself
in Tuesday Etc Lester claimed the police
that he opened fire to the door of his
home without saying a single word
because he was scared to death of the
unarmed teen Clay County prosecutor
Thompson said Monday that there appears
to be a racial component of the case but
he clarified the probable cause
statement did not indicate that the case
was racially motivated according to the
charging documents Lester told police
after he shot Ralph that was the last
thing he wanted to do but says he
believed he was protecting himself
against a physical confrontation which
he would not have been prepared for
given his Advanced age Lester pointed to
Ralph's size which he claimed was six
feet and Lester's inability to defend
himself as the reasoning behind his
actions the original story let me
actually uh pull up the archive so you
can see how they've manipulated this
said that the teenager
grabbed the door and was trying to open
it
and uh Time Magazine of course
changes the story so let me uh pull up
the archive pop it on over and we'll uh
we'll scroll down to what it originally
said and uh oh this is the original it
says the shooter's not identified
so even then wow they don't even have
the uh
the earliest version of the story
doesn't have anything in it this is one
of the problems with stealth editing so
let's jump back to uh the middle one
see if I can find where they wrote that
this kid didn't just ring the doorbell
but he actually tried entering the house
so let's uh we'll scroll down okay why
was the shooter released
man this is the hard thing about how
they keep changing the story you know
what I'll do I'll pull it up on my
Twitter so I saw that somewhere it may
have been on your Twitter but also they
keep changing the story this is the
problem with stealth editing it's so
annoying it's not like I'm trying to
pull it up this is all so soon after the
incident and we don't know most of the
facts if we've learned one thing from
these kinds of stories is you have to
wait for all the facts to come out but
as sad as this is
what really got me about it today was
when the White House started commenting
on it they revealed that president had
called the victim which is appropriate
you know if you want to express sympathy
and that sort of thing but Joe Biden
told people not too long ago during the
whole gun control debate after Trayvon
Martin
Joe Biden told people to shoot through
their front door
if they wanted someone to go away this
is Joe Biden I don't know if you can
pull it up I think it was uh 2013 yeah
and conservatives made a big deal out of
it at the time because it's such
ridiculous advice that most reasonable
gun owners would know that that's really
stupid just to shoot through a door
without opening it or whatever
he said that he gave his wife that
advice and that she was told to use the
shotgun and just shoot through the front
door if you're scared
this guy followed Joe Biden's advice so
I want to correct you I actually had the
wrong link I had the wrong link but they
they do change the story but it was a
wrong link here's what it says excerpts
of the prosecutors probable cause
statement posted online revealed that
Lester told police he picked up his gun
after hearing the doorbell ring while
lying down he opened an interior door
and saw a black male approximately six
feet tall pulling on the exterior door
of his house believing it was a breaking
attempt he fired twice after opening the
door
man I have an anecdotal experience kind
of like this I went to my friend's
childhood friend's house four years ago
hadn't seen his parents in a couple
decades 15 years and they were like my
second parents growing up and I went and
I knocked he opened the door and I was
like Hey and he was like who are you and
I started to hug him and he got back and
was like who are you and I was a it's
Ian and he went oh but there was a
moment where if he was this 84 year old
if he was older 84 year old man maybe
he's been drinking his mind isn't where
it used to be
for them to let you in every time I this
sounds like it was a big accident it
sounds like this came into the wrong
house it's not like he did nothing wrong
but they're turning into this black
lives matter racist thing when the story
is yo you go to an old man's house
and then you try opening the door and
gaining entrance to his house I don't
know about Missouri but in many states
people have the legal right to use
lethal Force to stop you from committing
a burglary yes burglary is not about
intention I don't think burglary is just
about the act of entering isn't it I
mean if you're not correct yeah burglary
is crossing a property barrier so if
that's the case this kid was
burglarizing that guy's house and and
yeah in the mind of the homeowner no
factually grab the handle and started
open it but the guys opened the door so
maybe it seemed like an invitation I
mean this is sketchy and the kid's not
going to get charged with Berkeley I
would die no of course not but but this
is this this is the reality I don't
think there is in turn it's not going to
get charged there's no criminal burglary
but I think in terms of the self-defense
claim there is an element of burglary
people think burglary means theft it
doesn't it means like crossing a barrier
onto someone's property so I learned
this the hard way
if you have no signs on your property
anyone's allowed to enter your property
they can't walk up to your house and
cross a barrier though however if the
screen like let's say let's say the door
is open they can walk in your house
they're legally allowed to and all you
can do is tell them to leave yeah if
your front door is open and no signs
people just walk in people are legally
allowed to walk into your home if the
door is unlocked clarified yep so if
unlocked or unlocked unlocked oh
unlocked unlocked yup we dealt with this
one personally when we had when we had
someone come onto this property it
happened more than once
the police were like okay
entering the house is potentially
burglary in the lowest degree it's a
misdemeanor and here's what you get
because you're not supposed to enter
someone's house like that however they
still have an argument over why they
think they were entitled to enter the
house
if someone says there was no intent it
was an accident I went to the wrong
house you're not going to get criminally
charged so I'm not saying anyone can
just walk in any house they want if a
kid accidentally walks in the wrong
house there's no criminal charges
nothing happened if you put up a sign
that says no trespassing now they've
trespassed when they walk past it now
you can have them trespass which is a
slap on the rest and the police will
remove them if you take the thinnest of
string and wrap it around your front
yard
and someone steps over it they've now
committed burglary
that simple it's the craziest thing well
the other interesting thing about this
is what they didn't charge I heard the
family's attorney expressing concern
maybe outraged that the prosecutors
hadn't charged the homeowner with
attempted murder and they had just gone
for these other felonies that are short
of that and I think that's because the
police and the prosecution know that the
homeowner probably didn't have that
intent attempted murder requires right
intent to kill and and what the family
attorney wanted to see was
some kind of racial motivation that's
what the activists want to see they want
to see some kind of Criminal Intent some
criminal mindset and I think that the
authorities know that they don't have
that and I think it's probably closer to
what you're saying which is an accident
where maybe the homeowner wasn't legally
entitled to use lethal Force I think he
was
that's what they're going to fight out
and maybe they're just charging him so
they can start some kind of
investigation and satisfy the public
without people burning down Kansas City
or whatever but
look
this is all happening in the shadow of a
crime wave that's happening not just
there but throughout the country where
people are attacked in their homes and
in La we just had our mayor propose
hiring a thousand new cops that's
because Eric Garcetti her predecessor
bowed to the black lives matter movement
and cut 10 of the police budget and then
there's a crime wave in Los Angeles and
they wonder why right and
I don't know what is in the mind of this
homeowner nor does the family attorney
of the victim but certainly there are a
lot of people who are living very scared
right now and that has to play into some
of this I mean there's got to be a
certain amount of tension
and again we don't know the motivations
we can't read minds but what we're being
told to do is to read minds what we're
being told to do is imagine that this
homeowner had some kind of racial bias
and that's why people get set on edge
about this stuff instead of just waiting
and hearing and listening to the facts
and look I think it's okay the president
called what about the victims he doesn't
call there are a lot of victims what
about Nashville did he call them no no I
think Jill Biden visited a vigil for him
I was looking that up but I don't know
about joking about it
well you know the president hasn't been
to East Palestine boom right here
uh let me let me read this section for
you this is this is Missouri uh uh stand
your ground law and it says uh you can
use physical Force to defend yourself
yada yada section three such force is
used against a person who unlawfully
enters remains after unlawfully entering
or attempts to unlawfully enter private
property that is owned or leased by an
individual or is occupied by an
individual who has been given specific
Authority on the uh Authority by the
property owner to occupy the property
claiming a justification of using
protective Force Under This section a
person does not have a duty to retreat
from a dwelling Etc so uh simply put
it says A person shall not use deadly
force upon another person unless the
circumstance is specified in subsection
one of this uh
under the circumstances specified in
subsection one of this section unless
and again such force is used against a
person who unlawfully enters remains
after unlawfully entering or attempts to
unlawfully enter private property the
legal questions if I could put on my law
school hat the legal question here is
going to be reasonableness so you see
the word reasonably appearing several
times in that
the question is going to be was the
homeowner acting reasonably yes and and
you may think so the question also then
becomes is it the mind of a reasonable
average person or the mind of a
reasonable 84 year old who lives alone
and may have dementia and that sort of
thing because right if it's that's what
I mean right right so it becomes a
little bit different and
that's certainly why they didn't go for
attempted murder because they're I think
they're going to lose completely do you
think 84 I think Dimensions should have
guns
because they take their license away so
do you I mean he has to be second
amendment before you could say that he's
he's right we're making we're just
expecting and that's what no one's
saying he has to mention but that's
that's red flag law and I think if
you've got a problem with Second
Amendment you got to amend it before you
can take someone's guns away even if
they are 84.
do you think that we should consider no
okay no I think I'm not surprised he
said that well I mean if if anybody
needs a gun and defend themselves it's
someone who's yeah that's totally true I
mean like look I'm a strapping young lad
right I can defend myself better than an
84 year old man I'm not saying I'm gonna
go you know Brazilian Jiu Jitsu on
anybody but I can run I can jump I can
throw a punch old man ain't gonna be
doing any of that stuff he he needs he
or she they they need something to
prepare themselves now here's what I
think I think it's a tragic story but
you're an 84 year old man and you see
someone grab the door and try to come in
now they're trying to illegally enter
your property tempted illegal entrance I
mean look
when I first heard the story and they
claimed that this kid rang the doorbell
and you shot him I'm like that makes no
sense at all
oh and I got the quote Joel that you're
mentioning earlier from Joe Biden uh
this is from 2013 told Joe told Field
and Stream magazine quote if you want to
keep someone away from your house Joe
Biden said just fire the shotgun through
the door I hate him so much he is so
stupid this guy should should cite that
in his defense yeah I hope his lawyers
use it and say look Joe Biden said but
you know look the reality is
the left right now is saying he rang the
doorbell and the guy shot him through
the door and it's like well where do you
get that account from where where did
that statement come from
I gotta be honest they didn't come from
the kid who was in the hospital
unconscious because he was shot in the
head it came from like it came from the
homeowner I heard and they then twisted
his words
they omitted the part where he said I
saw this you know this this young man
grabbing the door to open it and enter
my property to his friend's house and
that and that and that sucks man but he
wouldn't go to the wrong friend's house
he was going somewhere he was picking up
his little brothers jeez now here's the
issue if this guy does get convicted I
will tell you what's gonna happen every
single burglary in home invasion is
going to be a oops wrong house
I don't think he should get convicted
for this because the guy was illegally
attempting to enter his property there's
that's right he was neither of them
should get in trouble I wonder if
there's if there will be like riots and
stuff like that there are already
protests yeah protests but I wonder if
there'd be like riots and stuff
definitely you know there's a much
clearer they're writing for nothing in
Chicago right yeah it's getting it's
getting to that time of year man a few
years you guys remember the Ahmad Aubry
case where the jogger was shot yeah
excuse me jogger the felony burglary
suspect you mean
I'm not that's not a joke that's a fact
you know the
controversy there was a lot lower there
weren't protests right away and there
was more of a consensus that what
happened to him shouldn't have happened
that he was that he was chased down
um and I thought that what happened
there was interesting because the family
attorney didn't take the road of
encouraging protests they went to law
enforcement they worked with law
enforcement they didn't try to make a
big national issue out of it and that
attorney also interestingly also went to
the Trump White House and worked with
Trump on some of the criminal justice
issues and that kind of thing and it
wasn't rightly or wrongly whatever you
think of the verdict it wasn't a case
that divided Americans it wasn't a case
that was used by the movement even
though the black lives movement existed
it didn't become this divisive issue he
was that but that's because
conservatives are feckless
that story was clear-cut wrong and it
was funny that after the Kyle
Rittenhouse case you got a bunch of
conservatives coming out being like see
the Ahmed Aubry case proves that
conservatives aren't racist despite the
fact they knew nothing about the case
the dude wasn't a jogger the prosecution
and the defense never claimed he was
jogging and the the argument actually
was that well most people believed he
was the guy on camera breaking into
those homes and so the story The the
criminal case became did the McMichaels
have the legal right to commit a
citizen's arrest and the question to the
jury was do they need to be witnesses to
the crime or not and the jury decided
you must be a witness therefore the
citizen's arrest was unlawful therefore
the death resulting from citizens arrest
is is Criminal
the fact that the guy who simply filmed
it got the rest of his life life in
prison proves that it was a complete
sham of a trial and a criminal case but
the fact that it didn't divide the
nation to me just proves that
conservatives
give up really easily or that they take
their points whatever they can and
they're not actually in this for the for
for the real the real long haul I think
a lot of the the media knowledge about
that case wasn't unveiled for me until
after it was over I I didn't really
learn about the intricacies until well
until after McMichael was in jail
unfortunately right and that's the issue
conservatives didn't pay attention did
not care it wasn't broadcast usually on
it was it was live yeah you could watch
the trial a lot what I mean is it wasn't
covered uh at Great length by the media
right or left the way that like the
writtenhouse trial was covered in his
quiet neighborhood I'm sorry it's not
true a CBS they were running the show
live it was covered as extensively and
the right ignored the whole thing and
then once these guys got convicted a
bunch of conservatives were like see it
was the right call and like I think even
Tulsi gabbard came out was like praising
the conviction and I'm like
it some doesn't seem right about this
like why did all of these people just
come out and immediately side against
these guys without knowing anything that
happened I'm not saying what they did
was a good thing they were told by the
police not to pursue Ahmed Arbury but
this idea that when when the Black lives
matter activists claimed a guy was
jogging and was hunted down by white
supremacists and lynched was a complete
and total lie and I'll say it you can
throw away all the facts of that case
and just say this a guy got in his car
saw the McMichaels driving their car to
chase after him so he picked up his
phone and filmed it they put that man in
prison for the rest of his life I cannot
even believe that that guy went to jail
and they did it because in my opinion he
embarrassed them and they and here's
what I think happened
the story died Ahmed Aubry dies and the
McMichaels say self-defense the police
say okay this guy was the felony
burglary suspect these guys did live
there that's what they assume happened
the guy driving his car apparently was
tired of getting crapped all over
because they were saying that they
chased him down or whatever so he goes
I've got the video and I'm gonna release
it so I think what happened was his
lawyer gave it to a radio host who then
put it online which ignited black lives
matter anger I think then the D.A said
you stupid mother
I'm gonna make you pay for doing this to
me what's that guy's name you know that
guy's name Brian something you can look
it up I forgot his name I think they
they did this because they were
punishing this guy for smearing them in
the National headlines and there was
just corruption
but there you go I mean even still
through this day they call that guy a
jogger it's like oh yeah 20 miles from
his house you know in a neighborhood
that's seeing a string of burglaries and
there's video footage from one of the
houses that was broken into which
appears to show Ahmed Arbury illegally
entering burglarizing the house
and then the media narrative as he was
jogging so you know William Bryan was
that his name 52 accused of joining
Gregory McMichael yeah as they chase
down Arbury he wasn't with them he
simply got in his car and started
filming and they said you know what
we're going to put you in prison for the
rest of your life for filming this
that's a lesson to everybody Roddy Brian
Roddy's nickname and it's funny when
like you look at their faces in the
trial when they're found guilty they're
like shocked how could this have
happened and that dude if he just did
not release the footage it was it was
self-defense the Ahmed Aubry runs up to
the McMichaels uh attacks him they fight
over the shotgun and then he gets he
gets shot and it's like I wish it didn't
happen I mean it sucks and there's a
there's a good argument to be made if I
was Ahmed Aubry and I had a car behind
me and I had a car in front of me I
might think fight or flight too so I can
understand that but this idea that he
was some innocent jogger is just
ridiculous and I I there you go but uh
the funny thing is
The Narrative is going to be the
narrative if conservatives aren't paying
attention don't know anything about the
case they're just going to say whatever
the left said because even talking about
Ralph yarl is entertaining the left's
decision to make this the national story
instead of that white woman who got
choke slammed by a by a mob of black
teenagers but if talking about the Ralph
Laurel case makes it so that neither of
these people are charged and Ralph
survives and maybe the two of them can
even make amends or something like that
would be
fantastic that would be agreed outcome
I'd like to say and the outcome I want
to see in the long run is we set the
narrative and we set the tone and we
decide what stories need to get National
prominence and I hope we get to that
point so long as we keep doing shows
like this and it gets the point where
New York Times or CNN can say take a
look at this instance of a shooting that
happens all the time but we decided to
highlight on racial grounds and then
everyone just says I'm not interested in
talking about that for the time being we
may be prominent in media but we're not
the corporate press and we're not as big
essay CNN despite the fact their ratings
are in the gutter YouTube puts them on
the front page so it's our job to debunk
their lives hopefully it will be the job
of some other young upstart to debunk
our mistakes and errors in the future
because we will be setting the narrative
hear that you're listening well I think
if I can just shift slightly here to
something I mentioned you before but
the job that this show does I think in
terms of providing Free Speech as much
free speech as we're allowed to have I
suppose is really really important and
the Kanye West show I think was a great
moment in journalism because rather than
following the herd of the mainstream
media and boycotting him and calling for
him to be shunned you allowed him an
opportunity to defend himself and he
walked away
whether that was real or not what we saw
as viewers was a debate that was fair
questions that were Fair free speech and
he couldn't handle it and he left and
that did more to debunk what he was
saying than Ari Emmanuel in Hollywood
organizing boycotts not just of
Hollywood people in his industry but
every industry thereby
mistakenly giving life to the conspiracy
theory that Kanye West was spinning so I
thought what you did was great and I
think that's an example for the young up
starts to follow you don't win by
shutting other people down you win by
opening debate challenging people and
you weren't even you know and especially
not Kanye West the thing with him the
boycotts were actually making people
double down on their support of him you
know they say that the the best way to
get rid of a bad idea is to put a
spotlight on it right everyone can see
how bad it is well that's the big
problem with censorship online it's got
it backwards it's trying to hide the bad
ideas so then they're going to percolate
grow and the pressure will build but if
you let them come out in an environment
where they can be communicated about not
just a one-sided you know guy on a
camera yelling but like in a round table
of people that are listening man it
changes the thing the thing about yeah
he's got a lot of people who just follow
him and are going to go along with what
he says because he's a billionaire
successful musician cultural icon
if you just shut him down all you're
doing is telling his core fans the only
information you can get is from him
you need to have him sit down and just
talk about these ideas because then
those people are going to be listening
to him say those ideas and go I don't
know if that makes sense you know you
can still like yay and be like I don't
know if what he said made sense but if
he's never challenged because you refuse
to challenge him well then he's going to
win and we did a show or the weekend I
don't know if you guys saw it we did a
Tim cast IRL and then uh mines on Friday
at the Vulcan gas company mines did an
event on Saturday Destiny was on Stephen
Bonnell been on the show a couple times
and he was there
a challenging challenging challenging
even maybe even saying bad ideas I don't
know not saying you're saying but I'd
like to review the tape I believe Alex
Jones came out Jack besobic was there
Libby yemons was there we had a
fantastic huge rotating group of people
coming in and out and it was it was
really nice to let let ideas show
themselves for what they are rather than
rather than demonizing the people that
happen to be the ones that have them at
that moment
yeah I digress we'll check out the video
If you haven't seen it it's on Steven's
Rumble channel so we see the uh that
video of that woman being choke slammed
and it's got I think like 12 or 13
million views so clearly it matters to
people and it's being shared like crazy
but uh where's the New York Times
headlines how could I think it's because
the video's so blurry I couldn't really
tell what was going on when I saw it
apparently it doesn't really think that
it's just the blurriness is wise and not
being shared I really think it's
probably ideological from The New York
Times it could be but what they want is
clicks so if it's a video of a hand
going up and you see her eyes and the
struggle that's gonna get clicks and I
think that would get a lot of attention
I think that the video is dramatic
enough to get clicks because it has
million Tim just said it has a million I
think that there I really do think that
it's ideological it's clear what's
happening in the video too yeah if she's
there you can see her there and then
it's just pummeling from the top I don't
know I yeah I think she people are
arguing that they pulled her away and
then beat the other guy but I'm like you
don't know that you can say they beat
the other guy too but all I see her is I
all I see is she gets choked slammed to
the ground and then they start wailing
on you can literally see it it's it's
cool you can't see her getting hit but
you can't see her going anywhere like
she doesn't get up and walk away you
just look at choke slime and then
they're pounding on someone on the
ground yeah that's the thing is you see
everyone you see her there and then you
don't see her there and then you see
people you know punching towards the
ground it's like but you do see that
being a guy they are beating a guy you
can see that guy getting correct yes did
she survive well yeah okay so there's a
question I have about this also was
which is were they attacked or targeted
because the guy she was with
is black as well was it an interracial
couple that was targeted by the model no
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time